[Music]
Disney theory
Aladdin takes place 10,000 years in the
future Disney theories are the best we
love looking at our classic favorites in
a new light this theory about Aladdin is
a fan favorite stick around until the
end to see how important Jasmine's
attitude is to this theory new to the
things hit the subscribe button and give
this video a big thumbs up now let's
jump right into the theory okay so we
know you love the Latin we all do it's
one of the best films to come out of the
Disney Renaissance in the 1990s it has
it all big musical numbers daring
adventure and a love story for the ages
the princess is strong and beautiful and
the animals are all adorable and
super-smart plus everyone loves Genie
he's probably the most hilarious Disney
character ever written nice to be back
ladies and gentlemen hi where are you
from what's your name Aladdin is
definitely a masterpiece you've probably
watched it over and over right well get
ready to see this film in a whole new
light what if we told you aloud and
didn't take place in an ancient city
what if the movie is set ten thousand
years in the future it may seem like a
stretch but once you consider all of the
evidence the case is clear what evidence
to us well let's start with Genie at the
beginning of the film Genie is
dramatically woken from the lamp the
first thing he says is that he's been
asleep for ten thousand years ten
thousand years will give you such a
crick in the neck sure he's a magical
genie so maybe his perception of time is
different from ours let's assume for a
minute that Genie experiences time the
same way we do if he spent ten thousand
years in the lamps and the film must
take place ten thousand years after the
last thing genie remembers to guess
exactly when the story is happening we
have to look closely at all of the
things Genie talks about he definitely
makes some comments and statements that
suggests he's been around in our modern
world when Aladdin wishes to be made
into a prince genie gives him an epic
makeover there really aren't enough man
makeovers in Disney films so this scene
is amazing that fez and best combo is
much too third century genie gets a
little critical of Aladdin's look he
tells him Nia's Fez and best combo is a
little bit too third son
so we know that Jeannie has seen men's
fashion in the third century we know
Jeannie was asleep for 10,000 years so
that means the earliest Aladdin could
possibly be set is ten thousand three
hundred that's just the tip of the sand
dune Jeannie gives even more hints that
the film takes place well after the 20th
century he makes reference to a ton of
mainstream movies shows books and actors
from the 1970s 80s and 90s
how could Jeannie know who Jack
Nicholson is if he hasn't lived through
the modern era
how could he impersonate Arnold
Schwarzenegger if he'd never seen him
act he couldn't
it's simply obvious that genius very
well-versed in twentieth-century
entertainment that means that the
earliest year the movie could take place
is eleven thousand nine hundred seventy
you want to get even more specific
Jeannie's references seem to end with
the early 1990s he doesn't know about
the Royal Wedding or smartphones is this
because the apocalypse happened in 1992
according to the math in this theory
that means the film must be set in
eleven thousand nine hundred and ninety
two Disney release the film one year
after the Gulf War is it possible that
this is an alternate universe in which
the desert skirmish escalated into World
War three Disney creators have said the
movie setting is based on Iraq that
could mean a goal for TYIN is real where
the bomb scene in the video game a hint
genie actually drops his first clue that
it's the future in the first scene the
movie opens on a desert merchant allowed
instructor Ron Clements has already
confirmed the fan theory that the
merchant is genie in disguise I mean
come on he had four fingers and the same
corny jokes the creator's planned for
the merchant to reveal himself at the
end of the film but they cut the scene
in the editing he offers the audience
Tupperware Tupperware was invented in
1946
this proves that genie experienced the
modern world during the song never had a
friend like me genie references tons of
things from the modern world he turns
himself into a slot machine
those weren't invented until 1895 he
also turns his tale into a microphone
the style of the microphone he creates
wasn't seen until the 1960s genie
creates a Vegas style sign moments after
meeting Aladdin for the first time he is
obviously familiar with
lights light bulbs and electricity he
references fireworks the modern boxing
ring sneakers and cars there's no way he
could have guessed that those things
would have been invented with such
accuracy some fans have argued that
Jeannie knows about all of this
futuristic stuff because he can see into
the future the film makes it clear that
he can't Genie and Aladdin have an
agreement genie will grant his wishes
only if he uses his last wish to set
genie free genie has no idea lad and has
no intentions to set him free
I'll do it I'll set you free uh-huh yeah
he also doesn't see a coming when
Aladdin tricks him into a free wish when
he bets him that he can't get Aladdin
out of the Cave of Wonders genie is
totally shocked and had no idea what had
hit him his jaw was literally dropped if
he could see into the future he wouldn't
have been so shocked so what was the
catastrophic event that wiped out most
of civilization and sent humanity back
to the bronze age if you played the
official video game you might have seen
a clue if you watch the background
carefully Agrabah is a wasteland
Aladdin walks by Dunes filled with human
skeletons in one scene it looks like
there's an atomic bomb in the desert
there are also 20th century road signs
in the background what about the Cave of
Wonders could this have been an
underground bomb shelter it seems to be
filled with gold which is something
modern survivalist stockpile it wouldn't
make sense to create a hoard of
universally valuable things if there was
a threat of nuclear war
gold could be used in any culture to
trade for other goods in an emergency
inside the cave there seems to be a lot
of advanced technology as well the
entrance rises up out of the desert as
if it's enchanted what if it isn't magic
but machinery that makes the cave appear
inside the cave Aladdin finds carpet the
film tries to pass him off as magic but
we're not buying it carpet is actually
long-lost hover technology what happened
to the rest of the world during the
magic carpet ride aladdin and Jasmine
seem to visit half of the known world
the amount of distance they cover would
be absolutely impossible in one night
it's a magic carpet that flies not
Santa's sled if this theory is true then
Genie created all of those locations
from memory he gave the pair a Romantic
memory but
it was real this suggests that maybe
those places didn't survive the
catastrophe at the end of the movie
Jamie leaves to travel the world in the
sequel he returns a few minutes later he
claims to have been to Disneyland and
has loads of souvenirs for his friends
supporters of the Future theory claimed
that Jamie left Agrabah and found the
rest of the world in shambles he
couldn't bear to share that news so he
made a bunch of fake gifts to convince
everyone that the world was still out
there
Agra buzz culture gives us a clue that
the film is say in the future - it's
obvious that the movie is set in the
Middle East we can tell based on the
language architecture and various
cultural references one thing we don't
see that we would expect in the ancient
Middle East is Islam this ancient
religion seems to be missing from the
movie we don't see any mosques in
Agrabah jasmine is also showing her
midriff and allowing her hair to be seen
by a stranger at no point does anyone
participate in the prayers that happened
several times a day in an Islamic
country the characters do make reference
to Allah this shows that they know about
the religion but that society has long
ago relaxed its rules
agrabuff animals seem to have been
affected by some kind of global event -
in one scene the fish at the market are
just comically huge this could be a
mutation after the fish were exposed to
radiation or fallout from a bomb
mutations might explain why Thiago can
speak he doesn't just talk up a storm in
his awful voice he regenerates - after
we seem too far Byrne Iago his feathers
seemed to have grown back at an alarming
rate Iago isn't alone in his uniqueness
Raja seems to be able to communicate
with Jasmine there are a few futuristic
explanations for this it's possible that
Raja is also a radiation mutant or maybe
jasmine has a hi-tech translator could
those huge gold earrings be helping her
understand her best friend Abu is
another great example of how advanced
the animals in this world seem monkeys
are smart but Abu regularly outsmarts
adult humans that's not easy for any
animal he seems to mimic speech and has
no problem communicating with Aladdin
Jasmine herself is a huge clue about
what era the movie takes place in we've
talked about how
uncovered hair and exposed midriff just
don't jive with the culture or religion
of the Middle East
she even seems to be wearing makeup in
the movie it's not just her appearance
that points to the film taking place in
the future Jasmine's attitudes are
extremely modern for a woman raised in
the Middle East standing around decided
by future I am NOT a prize to be won
she's independent defiant and stubborn
those are all of our favorite things
about the princess we wouldn't change
any part of her it would be unthinkable
for a middle-eastern princess in the
ancient past to defy her father
there would be grave possibly even fatal
consequences a princess of the past
would marry whomever she was told to and
not that an eyelash
Jasmine seems horrified by the idea of
an arranged marriage she wants to marry
for love which is a very modern concept
maybe she's so forward-thinking because
she actually lives in the future a
future where Islam is a casual religion
and women in the Middle East are
empowered to speak their mind perhaps
the most interesting part of this theory
is that all of the magic in Agrabah is
actually advanced technology including
genie himself you heard it some fans
think that genie is actually some kind
of holographic Android if he was
programmed with the catalog of human
history that would explain all of the
references if this part of the theory is
real that means he's able to create
advanced simulations as well the parade
for Prince Ali the magic carpet ride
around the world these were all just
Holograms
it's possible that any AI that powerful
could have been designed as a guardian
of future humanity and their histories
does he hold the information the people
of Agrabah need to rebuild is he there
to help them rediscover electricity cars
and more so there you have it Disney
fans have been taking notes they paid
attention to the clues in both the movie
and the official video game after
careful observation they put the facts
together the world nearly came to an end
after an apocalyptic event Agrabah is
one of the last places on earth with
civilization genie is a powerful
artificial intelligence that can create
convincing simulations the animals of
the world have been mutated or evolved
highly-advanced new creatures shreds of
the old world can still be found for
those who look carefully so what do you
think of this theory is a Latin set in a
futuristic dystopia or are the fans
breaching a little too far this time
maybe we can all agree that this fan
theory is way more plausible than Jafar
being a good guy
that one really is too far out there we
hope you love this Disney theory we'll
see you in the future
[Music]